last special on YouTube is currently at
around 12 million views you're very
early on the YouTube way for comedians
putting on full specials to their own
channels was there any hesitancy to go
with Netflix this time after seeing just
how perfectly it worked on YouTube last
time or was it always a goal to have a
full length 50-minute special hour
special on Netflix regardless another
great question Boy you know you know
your comedy Biz that's right
um yeah it's great it's great having a
gun aside because all the comedians know
all this and you can't talk to
anybody about it who's not a comedian
but you're you're a nerd like us
basically I love YouTube YouTube is
great it's great for comedy these
Gatekeepers stuck you know they're it's
a business at the end of the day so they
they got no uh balls they don't want to
take a risk on a guy or a gal or a
non-binary but I think I got the YouTube
crowd I feel like I won that fight and
then I'm like let me see if I can win
the Netflix crowd and alone in two years
anyway so I can just put it on YouTube